welcome to this video against Thomas
tennis only games against this guy it
feels like more but we're going to see
what happens um what do we get ice
playing this line how may I don't know
much about this this is the very
attacker oh so he's giving me the bishop
pair just like that that's nice he's got
some development I remember did I did I
i played this guy right he play he
placed this he is playing this regularly
right yeah I'm remembering huh it's the
nine th c6 and stuff hmm there might be
it's still 90 79 f7 rook f7 and I was
taking a bunch of times and then 95 ah I
came click on let's play let's play a
simple move him I've had exactly the
same I had exactly the same game
probably against the same player this is
not leading to anything for white but it
is pretty solid of course Bishop to c6
yeah it's really identical I had the
same game almost the same game if not
identical um yeah h5 yeah probably this
allows no castles not sure if that was a
good idea to allow it but it's not not a
substantial problem anyway okay check so
let's see how do we play this on Quincy
five I guess all right let's activate
you angling for Queen g1 Quinn to g1
check maybe p5b for now now that looks
ok if anybody black has the better at
taking chances and okay I have the
bishop anyway the bishop on g7 it's not
doing much this is quite clear but still
I rather have the two bishops they're
not and are threatening Quincy one yes
two
as to find something against this idea
something comfortable let's say as
mentioned also be five beef is in the in
the mix or is he planning something
entirely different you kind of surprised
sometimes what they come up with all
right don't think white has any
aggressive move and now he's starting to
think after blitzing out all those
committal moose
well it's it's somewhat awkward because
c4 is also quite loose after Luke h1 for
example I can take g2 and I don't know i
probably will take them looks it looks
quite strong because well the rook
doesn't have any great squares to go to
and how does he cover Queen g1
King situ maybe or is he just
disconnected that's an awfully long
think no one long is he thinking for two
minutes okay so rook g3 mmm check here
kicks it too I don't have okay I can I
can check on there and play Queen h2
come on yeah let's do that not think for
ages here taking the the rook end
indirectly the points on h4 and f4 when
you have to be cautious not into not
falling into some kind of self trap Wow
always cool if you if you haven't even
vaguely considered to move that that is
coming Knight takes is six grade okay if
I take on g3 night XD aid
okay so if i take it Bishop takes King
age 7 and f5 or what yeah this it is
somewhat dangerous
now I did not even think about this this
bloody more mmm okay come on let's play
play it simple just taking us taking the
stuff you
question is what he's doing now after
may I have Queenie for check or is that
better actually let's do that I don't I
don't fear that so much him check here
that that's not a big deal I'm a taking
g to end this end game should be fine
actually despite the point down his
night is kind of awkwardly placed oh I
was thinking I was a ticking listen horn
but I'm not maybe this kind of business
yeah lamb see this does not help at all
for the pin maybe I have not played this
badly I shouldn't have pushed the pawns
him really shouldn't
hmm not sure if he jack should have
taken all this stuff isn't this an
awfully dangerous pawn on the a pawn
yeah this is just promoting Bishop f7
I'm taking g5 and f7 and that's it
huh yeah it wasn't a good game really i
guess my resigns Chavo he just took only
six there hmm I did not see that at all
so we had yes and here a Quincy five
immediately was maybe even stronger it
okay he went here and now ok so the
compounds ought be five yeah it looks
good right but i was sure i wasn't
really considering this this at all and
it's not working yeah I suspected that I
can take but I couldn't really couldn't
really bring myself to do it it looked
took dangerous accomplice just saying
like wind cm yeah i was i was seeing
that far but i can really just go here i
mean here this is here takes h5 but here
there is really nothing yeah when you
see it on the board right i mean you see
how good this Bishop is as a defender it
doesn't even have a check or or a remote
threat and I'm threatening all this gym
now ok now this is this is of course
clearly me check clearly worse then Jack
I think this end gap is actually ok so
it's the calm saying 0.3 m this is what
I expected but I I probably miss plated
somehow I totally overlooked at that
this is mostly yeah weakening myself
this was a bad idea be sure before it
was it was also not necessary at all I
was thinking he just plays this and text
my pawns and I don't see what to do now
this is really just a pawn
possibly two pawns I don't lose I can go
here but it's just bad check with this
oh sorry but this I don't know this this
starts to get get tricky and after that
okay these pawns are dangerous the
computer says now 000 it probably sees a
possibility to sacrifice and so that
yeah after that it's lost yeah King fo
it's better and the king is trying to
save the day yeah and this is going to
end in a draw came Wow yeah and I'm sure
that I'm bringing you this is so ok this
is one of those most you so just
sometimes dash out a quick move with ok
at one minute but you immediately see
that this was kind of leading nowhere
and the bad thing is that he it's not
even able to do this because I take and
take f7 and then promote so yeah lucky
win if you if you want yeah I could have
one in the earlier yeah but I didn't
didn't go for it didn't see it should
have taken the piece ok thanks for
watching